كل نفس هو معجزة بالنسبة لهؤلاء
الأطفال الذين ولدوا قبل الأوان خلال الحرب
في قطاع غزة، فهم هنا لأن
القوات الإسرائيلية أمرت بإخلاء
مستشفى الشفاء في الشمال بدعوى أن
إرهابيي حماس يعملون من
هناك، وأن حليب الأطفال هو المصدر الوحيد
للتغذية هنا للكثيرين.
لم يتم العثور على الأمهات بعد، ولا أحد يعرف ما إذا
كانوا على قيد الحياة أم
ميتين، وصلت شا أبوات للتو
وتلتقي بابنتها لأول مرة
منذ ولادتها منذ 38 يومًا،
قال والدك ليخبرك أنه
يحبك، أخبرت الطفلة  كيندا صوتها
المكسور هذا هو أقرب ما يمكنها الوصول إليه
من طفلها الذي تم احتضانه بمجرد
ولادتها [موسيقى] جاءت
كيندا و11 طفلًا آخرين من الأطفال المبتسرين من
ألفا إلى
مستشفى العاصمة الإدارية الجديدة في القاهرة منذ أكثر من
أسبوعين  لقد وصل تسعة آخرون
من مختلف أنحاء غزة، كم تشعرين بالارتياح
لتمكنك من رؤية طفلك
أخيرًا
يقول الأطباء إنها ستتمكن من احتضان
ابنتها قريبًا. جميع الأطفال في
وحدة العناية المركزة لحديثي الولادة هم أقل من 6
أسابيع من العمر، ومع ذلك فقد وصلوا  لقد مروا بالفعل
بالكثير في حياتهم القصيرة من
حرب ورحلة محفوفة بالمخاطر عبر
الحدود من قطاع غزة إلى هنا في
العاصمة المصرية، وأنجبت سان أبو همشة توأم
فتاتين قبل شهرين من موعدها، بعد 6 أيام فقط
من بدء حرب إسرائيل وحماس في
مصر.  شمال
إحدى الفتيات خرجت
من النك ويمكنها إرضاعها
في الحضانة لكن أختها التوأم
بقيت في الحاضنة
ولم تعتقد أمها أنها ستراهما
مرة أخرى
لأن الأطباء يقولون إن جميع الأطفال في حالة
أفضل مما كانوا عليه عندما وصلوا إلى الحضانة.  القاهرة
معظم الحالات تنمو بشكل جيد
زيادة في الوزن تصبح جيدة
الحالة العامة تتحمل التغذية عن طريق الفم اه بعض
المشاكل في بعض المرضى ليس
كثيرا في الواقع ثمانية تمكنوا من الخروج من
النكق إلى هذه الحضانة ولكن لم شملهم
مع والديهم قد يكون أصعب
من إنقاذ  حياتهم لا نعرف سوى
اسم الأم ولكننا لا نعرف
أين هي الأم
الآن